haha the Joe Rogan experience I have an
iPod Touch because the only that besides
that and iTunes did you bring it to a
museum I have no interest in having any
Apple products really I just I don't
need them I use a laptop that's a
Windows laptop though
I use mine does everything really yeah
of course you do
yeah you're a rebel well I also I mean I
remember when having to up and I've had
computers in my household since I don't
know when I'm not like I like some super
programming geek or anything like that
but I remember what it was like you had
to operate things you had to learn how
to use das and other operating systems
before that or using UNIX type base
stuff to get on the internet and do
things from the library back in the day
so for me I just want the ability to get
what I need and to have the amount
proper amount of storage is necessary
and then that's it my phone isn't for
holding music on it it's not for its I
have Spotify which by the way I've just
took over what used to be the adrenaline
workout Spotify playlist and now it is
the war masters workout so I put
together 96-97 songs for this playlist
for people to just go absolutely [ __ ]
apeshit in the gym and and get their
[ __ ] done and so part of my spotify deal
I am putting together Spotify workouts
hell yeah I have a cookout workout a
cookout playlist I have a workout
playlist I have I have a bunch of
different players
yeah driving playlist nice nice yeah so
I I now you have the war masters workout
so if you guys are out there and you
want to be filled by the the incredibly
powerful thing that is metal you want to
get some serious games
[Music]
that's it yes we got a motto Martha got
behemoth we got ball thrower we got
dissection oh it doesn't end I threw
like 50 people off the stage that night
buddy to the right that's Andy Williams
he's an AW as a pro wrestler right now
as well you see you know Keith all day
every time my guy guys Keith's up there
just like don't crush me mom up you're
trying to sing there's this chick who
must have been this tiny little blonde
thing who maybe weighed a hundred and
ten pounds at on her best day whoo I
chucked her once and she comes back she
goes I'm gonna do it while holding this
beer the whole [ __ ] time and mind you
it was a can but still there's a I have
a picture that I got from someone where
she's launched into the air
he'll has her beer she lands on the
crowd and when she comes back to
backstage she goes yeah I didn't spill
it that's hilarious [ __ ] champ the
only way I'd have to be a cam like you
wouldn't throw over the glass would you
no drunk
the risk is too much but there's moments
where you like you know no risk no
reward man maybe a shot glass I'll throw
someone what a shot glass right cuz the
shot glass is hard to break it's pretty
hard to break yeah but a beer like a
regular beer glass that's all I think we
shatter pretty here and it's just a non
stand a pit man it's bad news bad
[ __ ] news
[Applause]